my name is Perry clay bond I'm a
consulting professor here at Stanford in
the engineering department in the design
division and do quite a bit of work in
the d.school which isn't something
relatively new at Stanford my course is
ranged from courses on entrepreneurship
like Launchpad to courses on really
design leadership and innovation
leadership like design garage and the
course D leadership and on top of that I
I do some of the executive programs here
at Stanford really around leading
innovation and design process how do you
routinely innovate
I came to Stanford as a graduate student
I was a student of David Kelley's in the
product design program and before that I
was kind of did a number of different
jobs but it always had an interest in
making things and particularly in in
products themselves how they were put
together I'm sort of the engineering of
it is what brought me here so I took a
program at Stanford in engineering you
know actually took all the engineering
training put on top of that got the
design training which really David's
been a mentor and a and a terrific
figure and a huge force in that program
so in my career
I did some startup things after I left
Stanford so I did a snowshoe company had
some other startup ideas that didn't
didn't do so well but that that was
something I did for for almost ten years
and then I went on and actually took on
roles in different companies I took on a
leadership role at Patagonia the
clothing company and ultimately a CEO
role at Timbuktu a bat company and then
in the last two years have been back
here at Stanford teaching full-time
one from way back which was from the
snow shoe company so a couple years in
the starting atlas snow shoe company was
making these modern snow shoes and the
company was beginning to grow after
several use into it and coming along
quite well I thought we really needed a
low-cost product something to sell to
the masses something you could sell in
Costco or something like that
and that was the entire sort of design
directive if you will for this product
and basically produced what hid the cost
so I thought you know if we're gonna
make a product for you know twenty five
dollars or whatever the price was it has
to cost $12 and simple math and I'll
design that and get it done and the
product was sort of an extraordinary
flop because I never went and talked to
a single customer and the biggest thing
I've learned is you always start from a
customer need and work backwards my
customers weren't clamoring for
lower-cost products there were some
wholesalers that were capable of selling
lower-cost product but there was no end
consumer there was nobody in those
stores looking for the product there was
nobody wanting to use the product in
sort of the form I was going to deliver
it
in my early career I Dalby about an
entrepreneur and it's to me that that
defines sort of you know a master of
your own is starting a company and
running at being a principal in that and
and the driving force behind that and I
think particularly as I as I went to
work in other companies and and had to
drive change within other companies i've
thought of myself more as an innovator
and I would say that's really more how I
would define myself and I think it's a
much broader definition your ability to
go into a team and effect change into an
organization and affect change to to
drive something new out into the world
that has an impact I think that has
nothing to do with actually having to
have it be a business per se or or
having to be the driving force of the
owner or sort of the the only name
involved if you can be a member of an
innovative team and still be an
innovator
I've learned in my careers I used to
think it was all about creativity but
without implementation it really is an
innovation innovation is something that
actually lives in the world has a
contribution has an impact hopefully for
the better and that's that I think would
be what I would define as innovation
what I like about working at Stanford is
the culture and that culture is one of
it's it's it's fundamentally a
meritocracy and what I also like is
ideas matter here and what's different
here then then many places I've worked
or or other schools I've had the
pleasure to visit is oftentimes your
title doesn't matter that much if you
have good ideas and you're working hard
your ideas can see daylight here and you
can actually make change happen and I
think that's something I see is as part
of sort of the formula that makes
Silicon Valley successful and helps it
renew is if you have good ideas they can
they can go someplace